alright so here we go I'm going to go ahead
and is it going
I said there's going to be a quick video
about how to do closed captioning twitching
what's at me they saw this on SodaStream the
other day
and I was immediately intrigued I was like
wow that looks like really professional how
do they do that that's been around forever
apparently I just hadn't noticed on a few of
the few people streams so what is it you get
this get this closed captioning like thing
right here
two people screams instead of streams the
closed captioning is pretty good actually it
uses Google closed captioning it for free
there's nothing to really pay for and there
are some gotchas however so actually asked
her to be a grim underscore Grandma who is
another streamer that I like to watch and
talk to as well as the Linux gaming guys who
were you know as usual helpful but sort of
annoying
and they made a video about if their video
misses so many details not to mention it has
use a gooey the whole time I mean come on so
let me show you how to do it so the first
thing you do
is you make a script
I know you don't think you should make a
script but let me show you what let me show
this to before I do that so here's what you
get when it works
when it works you get this you get a no BS
that has captions down here to tell you the
pre at the it tells you that the caption in
real time that it's going to be putting on
your screen and it sends the closed captions
to the closed caption channel so that you
know you can use it now if you want to you
can monitor I just obviously just from the
screen and sometimes I do it that way but in
this case I have it
I just look at the screen up there and I see
what's what it's going to do is really great
it's pretty good for those people who want
to like I mean obviously closed captioning
is great I read a thing that says 60% of
everyone
who does streaming videos on Facebook I
don't know if that's a good thing I don't
have Facebook is this video silently so I
did not have a castle for this but I can get
the video I'll show you everything so and it
may seem
maybe it really isn't that hard as 80%
and I'm so here I hear the links to it
so it's the obvious project is where I read
about it the
and and then I linked to a script that will
do it for you and we're going to go look at
that script right now so I have a script I
think everybody should have their own
installer scripts because you never know
sometimes something's going to be on one
platform sometimes it's another sometimes it
just doesn't work so the main stuff that I
have I usually make a script to tell me what
I'm going to do and how to do it I don't
necessarily run it every time it's not
automated I just go in here and at it when I
need to so this was called install a home
yes I'm going to go see how the script works
and what it does and and some of the stuff I
had to add to the script in order to get it
to work no matter what so if you go to rat
with a compiler OBS plug-in that's the
plugin
I don't copy that link and I'll open it in a
graphic browser just so you can see it's
actually it was actually because I opened it
in a graphic browser that I caught the error
cell
I know it's one of those few times and you
can say using a text browser was a bad idea
because when I went out to the releases
they're just clothes capannari ice plug in
it has insulation know it's kind of light on
instructions for installation for for Lennox
and it says it's not working now this is a
thing you need to know what is it says
requires a 27 and mine
and mine is not do 7 to standard one that
comes with Papa West a little bar behind a
little bit but it's not too far behind and
then you go down here the Linux one and it
says the same thing it does have people
caption on and that says year
the anything after 24 has it where does it
say that
that's really messy dogs but you know so
let's go through what's required
so there's a number of releases
most the last two releases are
required to 7 or higher and I don't have to
7 so when the you know Linux gaming guys
said oh yeah she doesn't work it doesn't
work it didn't work I was right you and I
had to go back three versions two or three
releases in order to get it to work on my
resume over yes it does work you just have
to have the right information and just
saying it works cuz it was kind of you know
Annoying actually because I did have to go
through and look at it but it got me to read
this and that's when I read this it was just
a seven or newer and that obviously let me
to write a script so let's just jump right
into script obviously that's how I do
everything so that the first things first we
want us we want to see
went to show you what every step here
doesn't disrupt we want to see we want to
see if we have a couple beers at all so the
standard way is worse than politics and
everything is standard way to look up a
script and to i m anything to look up an
executable and see if it exists and get the
path to it is to use command Ashby people
may not know that some people use type over
yes this does not always work at will tell
you if it's there which OBS will tell you if
you have a an executable in the path
somewhere
but almost always you want to come and ask
me and you can read about that help command
it's a Bosch built-in desk be printed
description of command somewhere or to the
type built-in use the default password pad
everyone for what's the scripture for the
commander whatever so that does give you the
exact path if it exists right if it doesn't
exist it won't do anything so there's no
food so that's the real important thing here
so if there's no ovs this will be blank and
then this text to see if it's blinking is if
there is a gives you an error and exits
program so that's that's what that's at if
it does exist we're going to use dashes
because we need to get the version now
there's no clean version here so we have to
do
this dirty version and we have to parse it
up so that's what this is this is using an
extended regular expression people are
saying why don't use backslash D cuz that's
a pearl regular expression just so you know
so we have this as a new dose of parentheses
around each one you have the backsplash the.
Otherwise it needs any character so we're
looking for this right major version minor
version and password is not technically the
patches all that but I don't care so we're
going to get all that just cuz I found a new
batch rematches zero that would be the whole
match everything that matched but in this
case we're just looking for the
parenthetical matches which is the numbers
at the says any numbers are so high this is
zero or one or more of those numbers so
remember I once again always use double
brackets in batches safer it's the way to do
it if you're doing it with single brackets
are doing it wrong
you're doing it wrong it's unsafe it's a
necessary it's overly complicated you should
be using double brackets for double
parentheses in bash and nothing else soon as
you put back up there you've written off on
that this is bashus so then you put your url
no I think it's cool that get home is it
does have a standard location in their API
to get the latest and you can pull down that
API anytime but if the version is less than
27 then as it said in the release notes we
will actually want a specifically tag
release No thank God I just took me a little
time to find so
I was like Hey I just want the release I
don't want to get all the releases right if
you just do if you leave these the stuff off
do any of this stuff up here to get all the
release of some I know I don't want all the
releases I just want a single release and
the most people will tag their releases so
he
the release is so he can actually get that
by doing tags and that's what we did here at
this is the one I want is the one that works
and so this gets me the same thing as this
except just for this release it said latest
will get me the latest okay so so that's
that's that these double print that Ackles
are just the smartest easiest way to do any
condition that involves math and you can
actually do math in there you can add 1 + -2
and everything so anytime you're doing a
Bosch condition that has math involved or a
map comparison use double parentheses I
don't know why people are doing the old
ancient shit the gate so do this it's like
so much safer so much easier you don't have
to put a dollar sign in front of your very
real names it's beautiful it's safe it's the
way to go
so then we go down here and
we're going to grab the directory so we make
a temp directory that SD says to make it a
real people don't know about this game and
I'm surprised how many people don't know
about this game and this will just give you
a standard tip for a place that there is
temp space and it's very safe to do that and
then you just can remove it later by the way
if it has something in it you are forever
not just use under because it'll keep you on
save you from all kinds of nastiness that
you know it could do that and I'll get rid
of it will be cleaned out a nola commercial
file system used to be and when she just
lives in memory and these days not disc
these days temp is actually on disc it's a
part of who file system and it gets cleaned
up by a script that removes everything when
you reboot the so just know that
and you go down to your working directory
absolutely better to use parentheses
absolutely absolutely it's easier to read
it's what you expect it allows you do
mathematical calculations so you can do + +
+ + 1 + + 2 and I love that you can actually
do a mathematical comparison that you had to
using this stupid clue g2gt shit from how
these days that stuff is so old you should
never put that in a batch script ever not if
it's in a look as soon as you say you're
making a bash script you can use Bosch and
all the safeties inconvenience is a badge
and you don't have to regret it if you are
for some reason stuck in politics unsafe
land then you know you have to stick with
that but very few people are required to do
that that's the reason to not use seashells
seashell will ruin your day because it does
matter completely differently and cuz it
attempts to be floating Point method should
never do
all right so you show us a horrible mistake
people that have been Coating in it are they
have no idea how much danger there putting
themselves in if their codeine zshell if
you're going to code code in Bosch I don't
care if users each other's redirect the
Shelf I'd code in Barstow Echo working
directory alcaiceria go girl so this what is
this do so this is a silences girl Reader X
if necessary it goes to the URL and download
the file as release that right
I think I didn't leave something here
DirecTV now
yeah we share we should we should have
redirected into there I think I did think I
deleted something on accident
give me a second cuz we're not either that
or I did it wrong with plaster dish for
dinner. Yeah I did so wait this will
actually be the seed eater there we go
there we didn't see the internet was a
mistake and left that there from last night
alright so we need a to see changing the
directory and Dad's house when you're
working for his
curl
Dash SSL so that grabs it in the downloads
of all companies that Jace I think I might
have a release for you file on her nope okay
and then I'm going to grab the name off of
the cash to Json file so this gets the name
off and should we should we do this so you
can see it so
but bottom line we're just getting we're
grabbing or grabbing the thing so we can get
the the the data off of it now but I think I
still have unless you had curled Ash SSL
GPS API. Get out a calm repose are rats
are rats with a compiler
I think you need that OBS died captions
captions. Plug-in releases / tags / b02 at
1:18 be all right so that it now get the
file never go list of stuff that violin
release. Chaisson and now we can use JQ JQ
is the modern said I feel like it's so
significant it should actually be included
in the standard distro all standard
discharge but it's not and we can go grab
that thing we want and get the name out of
it so there's the name you get all kinds of
stuff we can get the assets to the assets is
a group you have to put a CD I have to go to
the McCords there's all the assets let's
look at the name of all the assets there's
the name of all the assets and I kind of
cheated I probably could have isolated this
more directly but I did and I just passed
out to grab for Linux
cuz I just wanted that one I'd want to get
rid of the the quote so we do. You already
get rid of the quotes but but yeah that's
what today so that's how we got the name
and then we come up here we get the URL in
the browser download URL as the magical
thing that you really want that is like
really amazing I didn't know it was there
before yesterday
and it's only on the releases 8 news did it
be a convoluted way to get this but this is
guaranteed to be good no matter what and
they name the resources right so that we get
that that's the URL that we need to download
so then we can obviously we can curl l o
that the data shows the capital O says keep
it the same name but and the elders
redirected kisses 82. So yes let me unzip it
and we get some stuff right and inside of
there is a big along the rectory this the
same name with this right so far without zip
on the end so that says move that thing in
there are called this which is the plug in
and move it into the standard plugins
location is it standard for all ovs on Linux
so if you need at Safeway I know that
because I already have the streamelements
plugins working for Lennox using this same
method so so there you go
and what else we got
I need music's too loud turn down so let's
let's go ahead and just remove that is what
the script it's in my dog files so give her
a .docx files are available over at it
started back to Rob's house. And then go to
cedi in to install and you'll see it in
there and you go get the script yourself and
do whatever you want with it you know it's
saved so far we've tested it and I want to
show you what it actually does so so that
puts a file in your home. Config Dodge OBS
streaming this stuff to some of the stuff
there at that plug is is a mistake and if
that's not a thing I needed to leave then so
here it goes here's a bath. Can take OBS
studio and CD into plugins I'm eating ice
cream keys or something here so don't you
know this is just
this Linux browser is something from
that's something for the streamelements It's
actually an amazing plug-in if you ever get
a chance of whether it it will automatically
turn any state full I keep the connection
open website into a plug-in and I mean into
something you can put on your screen any any
website so you can actually make your own
websites that that that tie into things and
you can make your own extensions for for for
streaming anything anything that you can
make a deal website can be turned into
something that could be put on the screen
it's pretty amazing so anyway based on that
but we're talking about that the Google
plugin so we have this this plug-in I'll
just wait for him out of it
as you can see there's nothing much in here
I just to show the library and then you have
to restart o b s course and when you do you
get this you get this thing will pop up
right away and it might all I got it so I
know tell you that is disabled
tell you that it's disabled and they have to
do a little bit of configuration which I'm
going to show you so you can cook on the
gear thing here
and you have to make sure that captures are
unable to hear you have to turn into the
source I put the mic if you're doing
anything fancy like mixing stuff might be a
bad idea to do that I'm really glad that
I've got a separate Mike channel for my
desktop audio I did that so I can filter out
music in my twitch vod's and it was kind of
annoying because you wouldn't want to
monitor myself I can't tell the sound levels
properly but I just use visual indicators
for sale Elizabeth a really great thing
about that isn't my mic is on its own
channel so I can completely turn off the
desktop and just have the mic still work
when I need to and also means is that the
only thing going into this look up shooting
ingestion is my mic which means it doesn't
have to filter it out we had somebody while
I was doing this noticed that they were
using something alive captioning it's a
plugin for Chrome that would do the same
thing but it tries to pull your voice out of
all of the noise coming from a given YouTube
channel or something or twitch stream and it
was failing and you like why I switched
it's more effective and I'm like because
it's just taking in my voice is not taking
my voice in the music like y'all are here it
it's just the only thing being sent to
Google is was coming into this mic and even
though it gets a pretty bad sometimes it's
still better A lot better because you know
and it forces me to talk to enunciate a
little bit better but it's works is
beautiful and wonderful so I said that
Captian sources heard on stream and that I
thought was interesting so
yeah I don't know what that is exactly I bet
all I know is that I put that on I kept
streams only you can actually do this for
recordings I read some problems with people
having it over take the captioning that
comes from YouTube and having like multiple
captioning on top of each other I don't know
if it's worth trying I haven't tried to do
it as a recording because YouTube does such
a good job at doing its own thing and I
don't normally have sound and in the
background I let you two do the captioning
so I Let It Be Strings only just for twitch
and I bumped the number of lines up to 4
and what is the guest call from Discord
notification I don't know what you're talkin
about
I'm just talkin on Discord if that's what
you're talking about I guess call from
Discord notification is that a thing
I don't know where and I don't know what to
talk about so so here we have lines at 4 I
put 4:00 because I talk really quickly so
that gives people more option their Force
line breaks I did not do that at profanity
filter off my status line taking calls I'm
just going to guess that means I am in
Discord right now and you can go into the
stage and raise your hand if you want to
talk about something have a question if you
want otherwise we'll just talk about
profanity filter off English caption timeout
I think I don't know I think that time I was
fine
because I show preview here and I'll just
give you a little pop-up box but this
preview is plenty good make sure you click
on Save and you're good to go it literally
just starts working this is the greatest
thing of although you can save transcripts
that go with your streams I've been saving
them to my zettelkasten Revo so that I can
grasp through my transcripts for that one
video where I talk about Dustin such I can
actually find what video it was on what day
and what time and when I talked about
something I can't tell you how valuable that
is even if I don't get the ACC correct cuz
my voice is unclear whenever the chances of
me being able to search back through hey
remember that time when we talked about this
and such and I can go back I can actually
search back through the transcripts which
are logged
and look at that stuff affect the kind of
want to do that right now I haven't done it
yet so the CD and is that
CD into transcripts and there's a my
transcripts for today
I'll see what's in here so there you go
oh my God that's so amazing isn't that
amazing that's okay
is it has it has the time it has it has the
awesome oh my God that's so amazing
I love that it's so amazing and has a date
so I can like search through so I can just
grab that stuff and it remember that one
time you talked about that one story when
yeah it's like if you're if you're somebody
who streams as much as I do and talks
randomly as enough about as I do you let you
know where this is going next right
you know where I'm going next to this right
the next place I'm going with this is I'm
going to make it so that my users can search
my transcripts for something that was spoken
on a given day for the last 60 days so I'm
going to make I haven't done it yet but I'm
going to make some sort of interface it's
already actually there right now because
it's in my metal casting so you can just
search anything in my stomach acid and that
if the key word will show up in a given
transcript it's also another reason that I
am going to start it's in my that's already
yeah it's already there
it's already in my stomach as I just don't
save it after each one I have to remember to
go in and save it so if you go through and
you searched my set and I already have that
right so is that is that query oh yes it's
okay I got you get it look like on the link
and you can go find everything in OBS that
is in a related everything in my zone Castro
Valley to OBS like literally every single
file that has a you get searching for free
if use GitHub it's one of the reasons I use
get her bra and I don't use a website if I
had a website I'd have to create my own
search index or hopefully wait around for
Google to get it this stuff is available
almost instantly new commits are indexed by
get him almost instantly so you have a
built-in free individualized search engine
and get home so some of the main reasons I
don't feel a lot of you know I don't feel
compelled to put a website out there
eventually so that it can be searched and so
is still have footballs up on search engines
but my transcripts are also in there so it
literally everything I've said that I care
to keep a note on whether it's in a stream
or is just me writing it's all goes into the
same place that can all be searched all I
have to do is build a slightly nicer search
front end on that and what happened boom
you've got you've got your own complete
search ability in that that's tremendously
valuable somebody like me so I mean that's
not the kind of thing that other people
reviewing adding the closed captioning
plug-in would probably talk about to me
obviously it's like really critical and
really important to be able to do that and I
want to make sure those doing streaming for
education or for any other purpose know
about this because it's so valuable not just
for the obvious reasons for accessibility
but
but because you get so much more you know
you can you can share your content you can
you can share your stories you can use it
for dictation it uses the greatest I hate to
say it but there's a lot of things about
Google I don't like but Google has hands
down the best natural language processing on
planet Earth my Google pixel is remarkably
accurate is still makes mistakes but it is
so accurate and you have that access to that
intelligence at mass of natural-language
model that they have used and constructed
over time it almost makes it worse than
violating our privacy for Less to do 15
years not quite at yes it's been able to
transcribe the video all by itself is good
and so then it'll really great thing cuz you
might do a video and you might talk about
something and say okay well what order did
we cover things in right so you can go
through the
video and search it I'm not prepared to do
put all of those comments in the description
section of a video I think it would be too
much text to do that but I'm not beyond
having a video link to the CC transcription
of it which is something I'm considering I
haven't done that yet but it would be rather
easy you just have to link to the GitHub
transcription and you can say hey do you
want it search for every word that's been
said in the same would you rather just go
read it all in one place now you can put a
link there just put a link in your video at
the bottom to the transcript and I to the CC
transcripts and they can just go look at the
file raw you can make a conversion about
that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I know that you had about
that so so that is the end of this video I
don't really have anything else to say about
this I am just super excited by it and I
hope that it provides value to two people
and it's ever going to put my vitamin to be
able to switch it up again if you want the
script so you can install the rest even if
you don't want the actual script it might be
good to read the script to understand how to
properly install it where it goes I prefer
writing a simple script for everything
because it's easier to understand for me
then to write the steps down written other
either that or make a video about it but a
lot of times just riding a nice simple
script as I will measure steps right there
are you just have to know how every one of
these steps is something you could execute
from the vast command line which again is
the reason that I use Bosch my command line
interaction and my scripting are the same
no cognitive separation between the two used
to be that's why I gave up parole for my
scripting and started using this at 5 on I
mean I still write those when I need him but
for the most part I keep them 1 to 1 so that
you know my my command line skills are
reinforcing my scripting skills and
vice-versa there's nothing wrong with our in
Python but when I write a python script now
I have to go look up the python stuff
because you know I don't do it everyday I
definitely do Bosch everyday makes me much
more effective so that's my personal take on
that hopefully you'll have a good time
reviewing this and I'm going to go ahead and
stop the spirit will be back to do some more
Sunday conversations and ask me anything
kind of stuff so see you in a bit